i will send us live and start the
recording
now so we'll be live in about 10 seconds
it looks as though we're live now so
welcome everyone to this meeting of the
cabinet
on the 8th of march uh and
do you want to do a roll call for us
please
yes so um yourself councillor jefferson
can you see him here i can hear
and see all the proceedings thank you
councillor pemberton casper pemberton i
can see and hear all the proceedings
thank you councillor barker councillor
barker i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you councillor cargill council
cargill here i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you councillor harvey council
harvey i can see and hear the
proceedings
thank you councillor jennings councillor
jennings i can hear and see the
proceedings
thank you councillor kettle uh
councillor kettle i can
see and hear all the proceedings thank
you councillor parry
uh good afternoon everybody councillor
parry here i can see
and hear all the proceedings thank you
councillor shenton good afternoon
i can hear and see all the proceedings
thank you we've also got online with us
councillors junaid dixon
and o'donnell thank you
thank you and do we have any apologies
for absence
no we have none do we have any
disclosures of interest members of
cabinet
take that as a no sorry councillor
barker
yes i run a food bank
okay thank you before we get on to the
minutes
of two lots of announcements to make one
i think to thank george hill
who will be leaving us at the end of the
month
and george has been a section 151
officer for far longer than the
period he originally came for and i
think it is fair to reflect that
george has done an excellent job in the
time he's been here
uh he's become an extremely well
respected
member of the team and we will miss him
when he goes
and we all wish him well for the future
i'm sure
yeah yeah thank you
and we are now joined by two
new members of cabinet uh rules jointly
shared with warwick district council
we have mike snow who's the replacement
section 151 officer
mike would you just like to say hello
and introduce yourself a bit please
no
mike you might be a mute
oh mike says you can't unmute
that could be a huge advantage for a
section one five
and we also have steve partner who's
joined head of assets
steve would you would you like to just
introduce yourself please
well i think i think i'm not on mute if
you can all hear me
um good uh good afternoon uh
councillors and i'm pleased to to uh to
learn
more about the uh the role of the
cabinet and what's going on here and
i'll
i'll be playing a very keen role um over
the next
months and years ahead thank you thanks
steve
uh welcome and we look forward to seeing
you at all future cabinet meetings as we
do to mike snow
uh so right without further ado minutes
are there any issues on the minutes
councillor harvey
thank you mr chairman can i refer
members of the cabinet to page
four of the minutes uh
minute number 539 um
this may or may not be an inaccuracy but
there is a difference
between the way in which we refer here
to the south warwickshire
development plan and the
south warwickshire plan uh being
considered by the advisory group
personally i don't mind whatever term we
use
one or the other but could i put a plea
in for consistency
uh thank you councillor harvey
councillor pemberton
should we standardize on south
warwickshire plan
i think south warwick's your plan does
what it says on the tin
fine so in future then in all documents
we've standardized on south warwickshire
plan
do you have any other issues on the
minutes councillor harvey
no thank you chairman any other issues
on the minutes please
in that case uh i propose that we
accept the minutes uh that we confirm
and then i sign them later
and i notice council of pemberton has
seconded council of pemberton can you
just
speak for the benefit of uh the record
please
thank you uh leader yes i confirm i'm
happy to uh second
the minutes uh with the amendments uh
drawn to our attention by councillor
harvey thank you
thank you councillor pemberton uh are
there any objections
i'll take that as a no in that case the
minutes are
accepted and moving on
to matters to be referred to cabinet at
the earlswood public space protection
order councillor cattle
ah yes good afternoon um leader
um i recommend this um
proposal uh firstly though i'd like to
thank all the community safety team
in including sam uh [ __ ] lensec
for their um huge uh
effort in putting this paper together to
resolve what is clearly a growing
problem in ellswood and and this is a
way to try and reassure
residents of elswood um i'm trying to
get some of the problems which have been
taking place there under control so
um i don't propose to go through the
paper
line by line which i'm sure the chairman
will be delighted here
uh but what i would like to just bring
up one small amendment
um and that is uh that if cabinet is
happy with this proposal the subject
council approving
the introduction of the public space
protect protection order
the head of community and operational
services is the authorized person
the purposes of clause 24 be of that
order
this will allow um this is on advice
from mr grafton monitoring officer
uh but this would allow uh julie lewis
to um act on behalf of the council
and therefore can designate officials uh
to enable the enforcement of this order
and clearly an order which can't be
enforced is not terribly helpful
so i'm happy to put that uh revision
in the chat if that would be helpful for
people just to read
um but that's really all i want to say
at this stage but clearly i'm very happy
to answer any questions
thank you councillor kettle i think
you'll be useful to put that
into the chat and then [ __ ]
actively for the minutes
uh and i've now got uh council o'donnell
and then councillor parry who wish to
speak councillor o'donnell
thank you leader it was just to say that
this came to a review scrutiny
on wednesday and we would like to say
um to express our thanks to the officers
especially to sam who presented
very well and it was um it was a
pleasure to listen to
the presentation with the culmination of
quite an awful lot of work over quite a
long timeline
um which i think will answer the
concerns of the residents so we just
want to express our thanks from osc
and say that sam presented incredibly
well thank you council o'donnell
councillor parry
thank you leader well i i didn't attend
the osc but i just having looked through
all the papers
um i just wanted to compliment the
portfolio holder
and the officers on such a comprehensive
report
i was particularly impressed with the
detail on the
public consultation and the approach
taken and i think it's
uh it was an excellent piece of work um
very thorough and i'm hoping it'll make
a big difference to the residents in
elswood
thank you thank you councillor parry
and i would echo exactly what you and
council o'donnell have said about the
quality of the report i thought it was
absolutely excellent
and i think the compliments are due to
councillor kettle and to
samsuments i think it really is
a very very good report
so uh accepting the
amendment that councillor cattle has put
in the chat
councillor kettle i assume you are
proposing this
um i would like to propose that i'd also
like to reflect that
99.9 of the credit goes to the officer
and very little i did
read it beforehand make one very minor
amendment but it all goes to officers
please make sure that that
credit is given we're credited to you
thank you councillor kettle
and uh i i admire your modesty
i see it's been seconded by councillor
pemberton
councillor pemberton can you just
confirm that verbally please
i think thank you leader i am delighted
to uh
to second the recommendation and also
councillor kettle's modesty
thank you uh so
members of cabinet does anyone object to
the earlsword public space protection
order recommendations
i'll take that as a resounding no in
that case we move on and it's the people
portfolio
notice of motion tackling food
insecurity and promoting food justice
councillor parker
thank you leader um
i'm most interested to have received
this
motion and grateful to have the
opportunity to speak on it
um in my own portfolio under health and
well-being
that encompasses so many parts of this
that i seem to spend my life at meetings
where food poverty
um is part of what we talk about at all
times
what i really want to emphasize is that
when we define
food poverty insecurity etc we really
need to be thinking not only about
affordability
but about accessibility which also
largely plays into this so if i may give
you an example
of the area in what which i live
we only for anybody who wants to use a
cheap supermarket
their only option is our local co-op
which charges somewhat of a premium for
buying food so here you just have an
affordability and
accessibility problem all rolled into
one because you could spend six pounds
on a bus journey to stratford to go to
aldi or little
but that would be another six pounds and
so that really
for me encompasses the entire problem
particularly
in rural areas um now
you mentioned as well in the native
nation um we're talking about
the increased um use of food banks uh
in the uk because of kovid19 i've
certainly seen that myself but i don't
run a trussell trust
food bank i run an independent one with
the local church in shipston so my
experience
although similar is certainly not part
of the trust of trust
experience what you need to be aware of
is that wcc
monitors all this and has taken
great care in collecting together the
details of all the food banks and
the um other food share initiatives
which are have a lot of them developed
and developed more since uh in the last
12 months
so you the motion answers to recognize
that food bank
uses dramatically increased i think
that's probably
fairly certain and that the pandemic has
contributed to food household insecurity
undoubtedly by the definition that we
use but i refer back again
to what warwickshire county council is
doing
um the family
poverty strategy was commenced
in august 2020 with a working group
to look at not only food in security and
poverty
but family poverty full stop
and it being made up of so many more
parts than just food
so in terms of each child having
access to uh healthy and nutritional
food well
that is tackled by free school meals so
the county council already deals with
that one
tackling food poverty may may improve
health and well-being undoubtedly it
does
but as i've just raised there are the
other determinants of health which i
will come to
under the family poverty strategy
um the uh the noted motion commends the
work of food banks in
stratford-upon-avon
um should i be amending any of this i
would be saying that uh it should be the
food banks in stratford or navon because
it's those of us across the district
i do want to draw your attention though
to the way that community activities can
work
rather than using national funding or
any other
funding from charities in my own area
a lady knitted hats raised 250 quid from
flogging the hats
and bought 250 quids worth of food
from the local shop not in shipston
which was then
brought to the food bank and i think
that's a perfect example
of the wider community in this in the
area in which i live
working together to tackle food poverty
where those who have
will do all that they can and it
certainly has
helped in terms of community cohesion
not just in knitting hats and selling
them
the national initiative of marcus
rashford undoubtedly encouraged the
government
um and so my understanding now is that
food hollow
is that holidays will be covered and
this the last holidays were covered by
a voucher scheme by the county council
topped up by the county council's
welfare scheme
now the motion moves on to what you
would like what
you would like council to resolve to do
well in terms of investigating the
causes in this district
i think that the family poverty strategy
which is coming forward
is undoubtedly doing that and it is it
will be coming forward in the next few
months
and food is only part of it there is
also the opportunity
to link into child care whether it's
affordable or flexible enough for those
on the lower incomes who are affected by
this
and i've also i've already raised the
issue of access to cheap
and healthy food and the need for people
to end up coming to food banks
whilst it is unfortunate that people are
having to use food banks
i'm personally glad that i live in a
community where
those who need it are supported
so the investigation is being done by
wcc and the welfare scheme already and
their policy officers
and the local poverty action plan and
partnership um
again part of the same strategy which is
tackling all
social inequalities
moving on to the uh final points about
potential sites for food growing again
i'm aware of
allotment organizations and community
orchards in various parts
of the district which happen already and
that they
are part of parish council's work
um in a lot of places i'm sure there are
councillors sitting around this table
who will know of them in their own areas
um and i would commend stratton on force
to anybody who wants to see a community
orchard scheme and community
allotments being supported and where
people help each other
press their own apple juice etc and uh
and the community impact of that is
enormous in what is actually quite a
remote
village um and in terms of lobbying
of course that's something that those of
us who are involved in health and
well-being across the piece
spend a lot of our time doing
um it's my opinion that
everything that has been asked for in
this is already
covered either by work that individuals
do
in the community which is to be
commended or
by the county council but if you link
the family poverty strategy with
the health and well-being strategy and
the the
the underpinning of that
um in preventing the inequalities in
health which we see
or at least improving the inequalities
we we are seeing people using food banks
for the first time that's one of the big
stigmas and one of the big problems
that's coming up with this
is new food poverty
but i'm not having fleshed out
where i stand on this and what's already
being done
prepared to ask officers to do work
on issues that are already covered in
many places elsewhere
so i would suggest a cabinet that we
reject
the motion thank you mr barker
can i just clarify that we've cons that
cabinet a considering
option a which means we're considering
the content of the notion at this
meeting
sorry sorry i've got a lot of papers
that have just fallen off my desk
obviously yes
thank you leader and thank you to
councillor barca for outlining her
involvement with
um many aspects involved in this motion
thus far um
at overview scrutiny we thought it was
actually a really a really positive
motion that was being brought forward
and we were hoping that you'd be going
for option c
to further motion to osc for
consideration for us to report back to
you because i think it's a really
important area
to look into further so from an ofc
perspective we were hoping
that you'd be referring it to us to work
on and come back to you with
recommendations and information
thank you council o'donnell councillor
pertigalla
i thank you leader um so i
i agree with um the the issues of
accessibility and affordability
uh which counselor baker as as i
outlined and also the work the worship
county council is doing
um however the
stratfor district council could do its
own beat
i just bring you back to the to the
alarming numbers that there are uh the
the
that we've seen in an increase of uh
food bank and as community leaders
we should be actually working towards um
ending
the need for food banks in our district
so um but i've already said in my motion
that
compared to in january december 2020
there was a rise of 59 percent
in in using food banks and of course
this is just with the trussel
trust network of food banks that we go
um and they include the stratfor donavon
arden and foss but obviously we have um
for banks like shipstore
and another foodshare initiative so the
numbers could be higher
um there is a fantastic initiative
coordinated for example by
by the marston sikka and quinton parish
councils
that covers uh most of my award so the
actual number of residents that cannot
afford or access
healthy or nutritional food could be
even higher
and looking at the most recent data from
suffolk bank
between 1st of march and december 2020
50 of all parcels distributed in my
world in the world of welfare donavon
i've gone to children and i understand
this figure has grown
here on here so of course
we also need to to bear in mind that
food banks are often the last resort
for a family or an individual we makes
these numbers even more worrying
the motion asks for a coordinated
approach
not to do this on our own and setting up
a food poverty action plan is something
that should be done in partnership with
other tiers of government
for example of course uh warrior county
council because issues like
access to targeted local welfare for
example
an uptake of free school meals are of
course under
the county council remit national
government decisions also impact on our
local residents
and may contribute to food poverty and
in fact the motion also asks for the
council to gather
evidence so that we can present these to
our local mps
make representations to government
through them and influence
national policies but what can the
district council do
well there's lots of things that we can
do and
that could make a positive difference so
sustain
uh as produce a guide for local
authorities to develop
food poverty action plans with several
suggestions
so we could live by example as a living
wage
employer and promote this for our
contractors and engaging with local
employers too
including in retail hospitality and
social care
we can use the planning and business
rates relief systems
to shape local areas for example to
support and encourage community food
growing
the creation of social supermarkets or
food cooperatives
as well as limit the spread of fast food
outlets
we could provide safe truly affordable
housing opportunities for individuals
and households who may be vulnerable
to food poverty and and poverty
and we also can coordinate messaging on
healthy
eating between public bodies and and the
other tiers of government as well
and the council will not do this alone
it's a partnership
is a community-wide initiative
and but the societal benefits will be
great
food poverty something that we can solve
if we put our heads to it
and council around the country are going
even further and have become
right to food cities and the right of
food is embedded in the united nations
covenant
on economic social and cultural rights
so no child should go hungry 21st
britain
21st century britain and we can do a bit
if it is of help
i can send material and research on our
councils can set up a food poverty
action plans to the portfolio holder
council or barker
and urge the cabinet will commit to a
food poverty action plan
and choose other options
rather than reject the most this motion
outright thank you
thank you councillor pertiguella
councillor pemberton you have a question
council of pemberton a question and an
observation if i
if i may um so can i just clarify
with councillor barker
that there is um a piece of work
in train already
um that would in terms
look at things in including
food action plans coordination of
messages
which my understanding is the nhs lead
on quite a lot of this stuff
but i bow to uh others
so can i just confirm there's a piece of
work already in train about this
is that is that correct yes and if i
just give you a slightly more fleshed
out answer than that
um there's the family the poverty
strategy
which is part of it but if you think
but if you think about what public
health does already and that is another
function
via um the county council
and the nhs's function all i can say is
that this is
this job is already being looked at a we
don't need to repeat it
b we shouldn't repeat it
and c i am not happy about asking our
officers to do a piece of work which
they shouldn't have to do because it's
already being done
thank you councillor bark okay i'll make
an observation
a leader yes so and there are a couple
of observations to pick up on a couple
of points from
councillor pertiguella um
there isn't there isn't anybody um who
would argue that
um anybody should go hungry in this
country
um and we do need to ensure that
people do have access to food but cancer
per together
did talk about a coordinated approach
i think in terms of the question of a
reference to overview and scrutiny
it strikes me that perhaps
this is a timing issue it seems
that any appropriate and relevant
overview and scrutiny
function in relation to this should be
in real in response to the piece of work
that's already
in train because to do otherwise will
second guess a piece of work
and does run the risk that overview and
scrutiny
may not be as effective as it should be
in helping shape a strategy because
undoubtedly the strategy will go through
the overview of scrutiny processes of
the county and the other rel
and the other districts across
warwickshire so it would seem to be a
timing piece and perhaps even an
opportunity
for ons to combine with other
authorities to to do a super review if
you will
um i would just say to councillor
pertagella that
we already are a living wage employer we
do insist on living wage in all of our
contracts
for suppliers um pretty much most of the
local authorities have had that on train
for some considerable time
indeed i am looking at a contract from
another local authority uh in my day job
which requires that we
confirmed to be a living wage employer
and my employers are living wage
employers
so that's that's already been be been
crossed out there
um the south warwickshire plan
is the is the area where we can ensure
that
further progress is made around housing
and
around things like orchards community
allotments etc etc
and that's that's the area where we can
we can we can make a difference
and i think i'm probably in the place
that says
if nothing else but for timing um
we just to do anything now does
to me absolutely put us in the place of
trying to second-guess something else
so i do think that uh
councillor o'donnell's committee can and
should look at this
that's a point in the future when we
have
a plan before us to consider but for the
moment i'd be inclined to say that this
is all premature
and on that basis i would be supportive
of the portfolio holder
but that's not to say that the issue is
not serious and it's not one
that we need to do what we can do in
conjunction with others
this is about are we going to do a piece
of work that risks cutting across
our partners and that's the really
important bit our partners are working
on this stuff
um with us so yeah for me i would just
yeah not not for me at this point
thank you councillor pemberton
councillor junard
uh uh yes as uh vice chair of opium
scrutiny can i
um support um the count the chair of
opium scrutiny that
uh i that ref option c
is to refer the motion to the ovied
scrutiny committee
it would seem sensible um to
have the county council's report before
the overview and scrutiny so it can be
timed accordingly
to make sure that we are scrutinizing
the county council's report
in order to find out how best the
district council
can work in partnership with the county
council
and others on this subject uh
frankly councillor junior does say no
reason why
if the overview and scrutiny committee
wishes to actually scrutinize the county
council report
why should not summon the county council
to overview and scrutiny
may i may i just interject that i
suggest that that's exactly what should
be done and it would make far more sense
when work is already being done which
county councillors
would have known about unfortunately i'm
a twin hatter so i know all about these
things
um and because of the health and
well-being intersection
it's not a piece of work that we need to
do
i would be happy if the motion was
withdrawn but uh
under in any event i'm promoting a that
uh
we do not okay
thank thank you councillor i've got
councillor kettle with a question
council of shenton who wishes to speak
and then councillor o'donnell councillor
kettle
thank you mr chairman um
i mean i i think um councillor junaid's
suggestion that let's have a look at
what the
county council had to say is an
eminently sensible way to go forward
um but i think what every council at
stratford needs to understand
is that the sort of work program that
officers are currently under
is i i suspect the chief executive i
can't see
i can't see him on screen uh would be
concerned that
already at the amount of pressure
officers are under um
it would be very helpful i think for
either the
chair of evian scrutiny or the proposer
to indicate
firstly how much time they think
officers should spend
uh on uh scrutinizing this matter
to put a report together and where that
resource is going to come from because
it doesn't come out of fresh air
and therefore another service is going
to have to be
um challenged by
less resource in order for this work to
be done so particularly as the works
would have been done at county level
so perhaps either the chair of opium
scrutiny or
the the proposal of this motion would
like to say
how much time they think it's going to
take and where that's going to come from
thank you councillor kettle councillor
shenton
thank you leader um it seemed to me that
councillor barker has outlined uh all
the agencies and the uh
initiatives that are engaged on this in
addition
i i unless i've misread um
misread this but the the department for
works and pensions uh
also have a an adult's security
module within their um survey their
family resources survey
excuse me um and that's due to report
this year sometime soon if it hasn't
already
uh i'm looking to cancel the barcode to
say let's see whether they haven't yet
thank you um and that
that that will clearly bring into
perspective
the food insecurity issues and deal with
the last part of this motion which was
writing to local mps
etc because the government are well
aware
of this and that and this survey is well
underway
and has been for a number of years so in
in closing i would say that i completely
support councillor barker
to view council barca's view on this
that there is no need
for for any further reports on this at
this point in time
thank you councillor shenter now know
your uh councilor donald wants to come
back and then councillor parry
and then we'll uh move on
councillor donald thank you leader and
can i thank councilman junior for a very
sensible suggestion there
that we look at the work that's already
in hand and also go back to council
catholic you must
observe counselor kathy you're slightly
combative about this this is a really
serious issue and it was a relief to
hear councillor barker outlined just the
amount of work that's going into this
across our portfolio
so derpy and scrutiny we will ask for
resources
and especially with serious matters just
like that noted
um i think as the work is already in
hand through warwickshire county council
who will be doing a sterling job on it
we call that work piece of work in
therefore we're not overloading
our sterling officers i think this is a
very sensible compromise to be had here
in a very calm and collective manner so
i would suggest that
we don't reject the motion that we are
looking at the piece of work with
warwickshire county council
and therefore it won't take any more
time from our offices but i would just
acknowledge the incredibly
serious aspect to this this motion and
say that over your scrutiny
um and i thank you again council junaid
for your sense of recommendation there
that we would like to look at the work
that's already in hand because there's
no point in reinventing the wheel on
this one
thank you councilor donald i think
you're absolutely right
uh that overview and scrutiny can look
at the work that's already going on with
warwickshire county council
uh councillor parry final words from you
thank you leader i just wanted to
reflect
um and really emphasize the the timing
issue
obviously particularly with the
forthcoming county council elections
it makes even more sense to actually
wait
until um the new intake of counsellors
are in place so that
over new overview and scrutiny can
liaise appropriately
with the right people because obviously
there's always change in committees and
that sort of thing
so i just wanted to reinforce i think
it's totally a timing issue and probably
needs to be picked up again once things
are settled down
following the local elections in june or
july time
but that was the point i was going to
make so really until then
there is no point in in in trying to
reinvent the wheel
thank you leader okay thank you uh
i'm going to i'm going to actually
move uh to a vote on the options we've
had a proposal from councillor barker
uh that we uh reject the motion
now the fact that we do that does not
prevent
overview and scrutiny from calling in
the work
of warwickshire county council and i
want to make that clear
but at the moment uh given everything
that's been said
uh i see no reason to put the office our
officers to additional work
given the work that's going on elsewhere
so in that case uh councillor barker has
proposed the motion
i will that we reject the motion
i will second that we reject the motion
uh do any members of cabinet
object to the proposal and second to
reject the motion
i'll take that as a no the notice of
motion
is rejected so
moving on
councillor harvey uh
capital budget monitoring period one to
ten
thank you chairman the purpose of this
paper
is to keep members informed of the
progress
made over the first 10 months of the
year in undertaking the council's
intended level
of capital expenditure this year the
position in relation to the capital
budget for the year
has remained unchanged since the cabinet
last met
table 1 on page 49
demonstrates the intention to undertake
expenditure of 11.3 million pounds this
year
including section 106 projects
taking into account additional funds of
2.9 million pounds
budgeted for this year this will result
in the balance of the council's
accumulated
capital receipts and grants being
reduced
over the assuming all capital projects
budgeted
are to be delivered from 6.4 million
pounds
to an overspend of 2 million pounds
paragraph 1.5 indicates that capital
expenditure of
1.8 million has either been already been
undertaken
or had been committed by the end of
january
in the first 10 months of the financial
year therefore
the sums either spent or committed
amount to
16 of this year's available budget
of 11.3 million pounds appendix 2
on pages 59 to 62
provides summary information concerning
the various projects
yet to be funded through section 106
agreements
which as indicated on page 62
have a total value of 5 million pounds
unless cabinet members have any
questions i ask
leader that the current position on
capital expenditure and
income for the 10th month period to the
end of january
2021 be noted
thank you chancellor harvey
council o'donnell you'll have a question
thank you ladies it's just a very quick
question for councillor harvey it was
more about
a presentation aspect of the information
um page 59
um item six there are some really
exciting projects in the
in the offing um i'm looking
particularly the one that's
the taylor wimpy offside open space
balance of 141 000 pounds it would just
be really interesting
on this page to have an extra column to
say exactly where we are
with these projects i know they are
both committed and uncommitted funds um
and there are some dates in the other
in the um final column but i'm just
wondering are they all at the stage
where nothing's happened yet
or is there any updates on any of them
just wanted any clarity around it's a
lot there are a lot of money that's been
that's been promised it's just
interesting
whereabouts we are with them um i'm
happy to take that question away
uh and regard it as a very helpful
suggestion i will be happy to discuss
with
uh relevant officers the practicality of
providing
the extra information counsellor
o'donnell has just requested
thank you so much council harvey thank
you councillor harvey
councillor harvey has proposed that we
accept the recommendation on page 49
do i have a second place uh
councillor shenton thank you can you
just confirm
verbally that you asked second in the
most
day thank you i'm very happy to second
the motion uh on page 49.
thank you councillor shenton uh
is everyone in cabinet happy with that
unless i hear to the country i'll assume
yes
agreed good in that case can we move on
to revenue budget monitoring and once
again it's councillor harvey councillor
harvey
thank you leader for the purposes of
this report is to inform the cabinet
of the revenue picture of the council's
finances to the end of january
2021 i'd like to begin by asking members
to turn
to endix 3 on page 73.
this shows that the net budget to be
financed by the council this year
is 20.8 million pounds
if we now turn to appendix 2 on page
71 we can see that the budget
for the whole year is for total
expenditure of 28.3 million pounds
and total income from various sources of
11.7 million pounds
the difference between these two numbers
16.6 million pounds in random numbers
together with the net cost of the cost
of benefits
of 186 000 pounds represents the total
amount
to be funded from various sources i.e
16.8 million pounds as set out
in appendix 2. in addition appendix 2
also sets out that as a result of the
kovid 19 pandemic
the council has received civil
contingencies funding from the
government
of 58.4 million pounds
of which 41.8 million pounds has already
been distributed
in ways consistent with the government's
intentions
leaving a balance of 16.6 million pounds
at the end of january turning to the
position at the end of period
10 we can see on page 71
that in round terms the council's
expenditure of 24 million pounds
was 1.1 million pounds more than
budgeted
this reflects a variety of decisions
across the council's activities
in light of the current very changed
circumstances
the impact of the covid19 pandemic is
similarly illustrated
in the shortfall against budgeted income
to the end of january of 684
000 pounds although there were
shortfalls in revenue of 2.6 million
pounds
generated from fees charges rent and
interest principally 1.4 million pounds
of budgeted revenue lost from the
district's car parks
this was offset by over budget receipts
of grants reimbursements and reincharges
of 589 000 pounds
the combination of these outcomes means
that the net cost of all services
provided
in the first 10 months of the year
excluding the additional net cost
of the payment of benefits of 511
000 pounds was 2.2 million pounds
greater than had been budgeted
section 4 of the paper identifies the
principal items of variance
from the budgeted figures during the
period april to january
whilst section 5 provides estimates for
the out turn
in a full year section seven of the
paper demonstrates
the severe strain that the pandemic is
having on the council's reserve position
which at this stage is estimated will be
reduced
from 8.9 million pounds to
4.7 million pounds by the end of the
financial year
to state the obvious the council's
general fund reserve
will be will have been reduced by almost
half in a single year
appendix 4 identifies the council's
current earmarked reserves
as they stood at the end of january
2021.
allocations of a number of these
earmarked reserves to the general
reserve fund have been made as part of
the proposals
of the 2122 budget approved by the
council at its meeting
on the 22nd of february this year
subject to any further information that
mr hill
might be in a position to provide about
the prospects for the last
two months of the current financial year
and to any questions
members may have i ask that the report
be received
thank you mr chairman thank you
councillor harvey
councillor junior do you have a couple
of questions
yes um i've been following um
what council harvey's been said saying
over several meetings
uh i've noted that for example uh at one
stage in august last year
where the district council was forecast
to have an 8.1 million pound deficit
at the last update we were forecast to
have a 4.2 million
deficit and now we're being forecast to
have a 3.4 million deficit
so things seem to be going in the right
direction
but just one puzzle i have which is
about the unfair
unfavorable variances forecast the off
street parking for example 1.4 million
planning 0.2 million now note what 3.18
says um that there's 613
1 163 of income relates to government
payment
for loss of income as a result of covet
19.
but the government originally promised
broadly that 75
of compensation for losses on these
items would would be forthcoming
so i'm just wondering whether um council
harvey could update me
on whether all the government support uh
that was
uh promised has been uh has been in or
whether there is
still more to come uh to cover some of
those at those uh particular unfavorable
variances forecasts that's one number of
another one which i'll come on to
afterwards
uh thank you councillor junit uh i'm not
involved in the operational performance
of the finance function on a day-to-day
basis
uh but i'm sure george hill will be able
to answer that question for you
yeah yeah thank you yeah um
we've currently made um two applications
for funding under the government scheme
to
support the fees and charges deficit um
that is the total of the six hundred
thousand the um
the the scheme was was uh
to fund 75 of the uh
loss after the first five percent had
been accounted for because that was
deemed to be
normal tolerance within a budget the
the five percent was all um funded in
the first
payment so that was particularly low we
think it would be
um 600 000 altogether but we will
finalize that claim um after the end of
march thank you uh
so so just just to capital or or to it
it looks as if we could be
in a in a better position than
originally forecast
um eventually if government comes
through with it with the money
um that they did indicate that they
would give possibly we've also
uh recently received the funding towards
the
the loss of income on leisure we've also
received some funding from the county
council towards
to help towards the homelessness uh
costs of the council as well
thank you mr hill councillor junior did
you have another question
yes please and this is on future funding
because i
followed the government's budget
announcements uh all of which actually
involve bidding processors actually
which was very interesting to hear
but of the three funds that i was
interested in
leveling up fund and a community renewal
fund and some extra money for the towns
fund
certain areas were given priority
statements based on financial
analysis and support from the mp i noted
that one of the areas was richmond share
in north yorkshire
and i did some investigation as to why
that would get a priority
uh given that it's one of the most uh
prosperous places in england
but apparently the reason given was that
there was an impact on
reduction in tourism on the hospitality
sector in that area
as well as mp support so given that
stratford uneven has suffered some of
the worst gva figures in the country
due to a major loss of tourism including
international tourism
should this constituency have had a
prior
higher priority than richmond and what
present
representations are being made to our mp
to make sure that this area
has due regard from the government's
budget
it does seem rather inappropriate that
richmond richmond
richmond area should be so much more
priority than stratford upon england
thank you
thank you councillor junior i must say
that i
emailed our mp this morning
uh we are already beginning to
contemplate a submission that could be
made
so i can say we are well on the case
counselor junior
thank you and just to finally finalize
is
the allocations are all using bidding
processes
will the district council reconsider its
approach to a dedicated bid support for
this council
uh the the answer is no but we will make
sure we have appropriate support to do
a bid the reality actually is bids come
in various shapes and sizes
and one officer may not fit all the
requirements so
we are again on the case in making sure
we have the
uh appropriate support to submit a bid
thank you chairman i i just want to be
my members we're actually discussing
the budget monitoring report for the
period one to ten here we're
well aware of the announcement in the
budget last week in relation to the
level amount but at this point
we are just um the debate should be
restricted to that about the budget
monitoring
thank you mr brooklyn but i think it's
actually
been very useful to highlight the
actions we are taking
at some pace so
uh do i have a second uh for councillor
harvey's proposal and they accept the
recommendation on page 63
thank you uh councillor barker in fact
they
just keep on coming so i am assuming
then
uh members of cabinet that uh the
recommendation on page 63
is acceptable
excellent in that case we move on to the
last items on the agenda
uh there are no issues arising from
overview and scrutiny
uh cabinet committees non on block items
uh we've got the member development
working group
and there's no uh urgent business
counselor kettle you wanted to comment
uh what was the issue you wish to
comment on
it was just to say thank you um on
behalf of
you thanks um mr hill i thought some
others who are interested in the finance
function
should also be given the opportunity to
thank george for his
very significant contribution and
forbearance and some challenging
questions
he's received over the past two years um
i think the only thing is whoever
allowed him to step down
made a terrible mistake although i'm
sure his successor will do
terribly well but george it's been great
working with you uh
and thank you thank you councillor
kettle
a nice note and we are here the meeting
and i think we all agree
uh how effective uh george hill has been
and he really has been an excellent
member of the team
so thank you george if you sail off into
the sunset or
whatever you're going to do and with
that
i now declare the meeting closed
thank you leader bye everybody